[موسيقى]
مرحباً بالجميع ، مرحبًا بكم في الدائرة الكاملة ، أنا
أندرسون كوبر الليلة ،
سأتحدث إلى فتاة
شجاعة جدًا ومغامرة للغاية
تبلغ من العمر سبع سنوات
اسمها ليزا سكوت وانقلب
عالمها رأسًا على عقب عندما أدى القيصر إلى  تشخيص
تشوهات
دماغية متعددة ستحتاج ليزا إلى سلسلة من
العمليات الجراحية تتراكم التكاليف الطبية بالفعل
للعلاج
وهنا جاءت روح المغامرة لديها حيث
أقامت منصة عصير الليمون
في مخبز عائلتها وكان
مجتمعها بالفعل
داعمًا بشكل لا يصدق و  إن
دعم لطف الغرباء في
إيمانهم
هو الذي يساعد ليزا وعائلتها
على الضغط خلال الأوقات الصعبة للغاية
التي تعرفها في اللحظات التي أشعر فيها
أنني لا أستطيع التنفس
أو الاستيقاظ في الليل ولا أستطيع  نومي
أنا أصلي أنا على يدي وركبتي
أصلي حرفيًا
وأريد أن أرحب بليزا سكوت
وأمها إليزابيث ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لكونك معنا
ليزا ، أنت مثل هذه
الفتاة الشجاعة وأنا أعلم أن هذا أب  ig week
بالنسبة لك إليزابيث ، هل يمكنك إخبارنا
قليلاً عن رحلتك
إلى بوسطن هذا الأسبوع ،
حسنًا ، لا أعرف الكثير ، نحن نغادر يوم
الخميس
لدينا قبل العملية يوم الجمعة والجراحة في
الجراحة الأولى يوم الاثنين
وبعد ذلك  سنكون هناك لمدة أسبوعين
بالتأكيد
، وسمعت ليزا أنك كنت في
المستشفى قبل بضعة
أسابيع وسألت والدتك إذا كان بإمكانك فتح
كشك ليموناضة ، فلماذا تريد أن تفعل ذلك
فأنت لا تعرف  لا أعلم
أنني قد ألغيت عندما كنت طفلاً صغيرًا
أيضًا ،
آه ، كان لديه واحد مثلك ،
ما رأيك في أن يكون لك
أفضل بكثير على الرغم من أن لديك
حامل عصير ليمونادة جميل ، فأنا أنظر إلى
صور له ، إنه جميل جدًا
ماذا تفعل  بيع هناك ،
هل كل ذلك مجرد
ملفات تعريف ارتباط عصير الليمون
، من الجيد بيع شيء ما لتناوله
مع عصير الليمون وهذه فكرة جيدة
إليزابيث عندما أتت إليك ليزا
بفكرة ما
رأيك أه تعلم أنها رائدة
أعمال في القلب وهذا أمر مؤكد
هي  أرادت أن تبدأها الصيف الماضي
وكان ذلك لطيفًا  من أجل المتعة ثم
اضطررنا إلى طرحه
أه بسبب فيروس كوفيد وكل شيء ، لذا
كان الأمر وكأنه على ما يرام ،
لا يمكنني منعها من القيام بالأشياء
التي تريد القيام بها على
أي حال ، لذا قد أشجعها أيضًا
لبيع عصير الليمون
، هل تعلم أنها
ستنشئ هذا الآن أو
ما الذي دفعها للقيام بذلك
كما تعلم
أم تعلم أنها ترى المعاناة اليومية
أه إدارة شركة عائلية أمر صعب
وهي و  شقيقها الصغير
هنا جيدًا
وترى
أنني أربيهما بمفردهما ،
وهي دائمًا ما تريد
المساعدة
بأي طريقة ممكنة على الرغم من أنها
ليست مسؤوليتها
لأعتقد أنه من المهم أن تقوم بذلك  تشعر
وكأنها تساهم
بطريقة ما